let's do it let's do some examples of
the writing expressions with variables
exercise so it says write an expression
to represent eleven more than a well you
could just have a but if you want eleven
more than a you would want to add eleven
so you could write that as a plus eleven
you could also write that as eleven plus
a both of them would be eleven more than
a so let's check our answer here we got
it right let's do a few more of these
write an expression to represent the sum
of D and nine so the sum of D and nine
that means you're going to add D and
nine so I could write that as d plus
nine or I could write that as 9 plus 9
plus D check our answer got that right
let's do a few more of these write an
expression to represent J minus 15 well
I could just write it in with math
symbols instead of what you writing the
word minus instead of writing MI and us
I could write J minus 15 and then I
check my answer and got it right let's
do a few more of these there's a lot of
fun write an expression to represent
seven times R well seven there's a
couple ways I could do it I could use
this little dot right over here who's
seven times R like that that would be
correct
I could literally just write seven R if
I just wrote seven seven R that would
also count let me check my answer that's
right let me do a couple of other of
these just so you can you can see that I
could have dust done 10 and this is not
a decimal this is it's a little bit
higher than a decimal it's
multiplication and the reason why once
you start doing algebra you use this
symbol instead of instead of that kind
of cross for multiplication is that that
that that X looking thing gets confused
with X when you're doing when you're
using X as a variable so that's why this
is a lot more useful so we want to write
10 times you 10 times you let's check
our answer got it right let's do one
more
write an expression represent 8 divided
by D so you could write it as 8 and then
I could write slash like that 8 divided
by
d and there you go this is 8 divided by
D let me check let me check the answer
I'll do one more of these six divided by
B same thing so six I could use this
tool right over here it does the same
thing as if I were to press the
backslash so six divided by B check my
answer and got it right